hey there welcome to the final
installment 2023 summer s'mores
um this is kind of the
post game the wrap up
it's been a couple of days
we've all had time to think about our
actions
uh to
um check on the police records to to
view the hidden cameras and uh so you
know I think of this as one of those
episodes they have after a reality show
is done when they get the everyone
together the reunions the reunions oh
and they're all on stage and we don't
look as nice I know but the point is we
talk about how Sona lost her okay
and screamed at me and then you know
gorley and I made out but we didn't tell
uh Bridget
I just made up that name
it'd be terrible on a reality show you
know it'll be happening on any reality
show I would just be
uh I'd want to work out and I would want
to get my sleep and I would rehydrate a
lot and the producers would keep nudging
me and saying don't you want to go over
there and flirt with the girl and then
have a fight with that guy and I'd be
like nah it seems kind of awkward wait
there's your cameras and you're you're
not going up against the cameras like
you'd be so drawn to the cameras
do we I'd be sitting at a desk working
on something and then occasionally
mugging at a camera oh yeah and making
little faces and thinking that that in
any way competes with two young people
doing it
rolling around together and I'd be like
yeah they can roll around all they want
with their fantastic naked bodies that
are slightly blurred but here I am
reading Samuel Johnson's version of the
dictionary
and making my Groucho faces to the
camera
and then pausing to rehydrate before
eight and a half hours of sleep nothing
less the doctor says
oh no no finally at some point they
would convince someone to come up to me
and go like hey Conan do you want to
make out I'd rather not
cooties I wear a wedding ring
this is my bond my betrothed
back to my Samuel Johnson uh
recap Gurley I thought it was a first of
all
um I thought I want to say a couple
things I thought the pizza was delicious
yeah
uh the drinks were amazing thank you
quite potent yeah wanna want to talk
about what give us your blow by blow
well I think uh they were maybe I don't
know if they were stronger this year or
I was more susceptible but I got a
little sloppier this year than than last
time I think I got up yeah you
did yeah I did yeah but it was nice I I
really like that Sona I like all Sonos
you don't have a bad drink personality
or some people like demons come out
Conan would disagree no no uh no no
you're a very
um nice and friendly when uh you imbibe
a sweetness there's a sweet person we've
had we've like fought like I've got I've
gone after you well yeah physically not
physically attacked sort of like uh any
uh animal uh when threatened
Conor O'Brien needs a friend is brought
to you by T-Mobile from listening to
your favorite podcast while driving
cross country to listening at home
T-Mobile helps you stay connected I
wonder what people's favorite podcast is
oh I've got some ideas actually it's one
idea yeah you'll figure it out T-Mobile
is America's largest and fastest 5G
Network you can have seamless video
calling oh that's good streaming your
favorite podcast I'm not gonna say which
one it is yeah downloading apps games
boy you know what a gamer I am you're
such a gamer play starbursters yeah or
realm of zanos
you can watch your favorite TV episodes
classic Conan new Conan old Conan
mid-season Conan as long as it's Conan
oh no find out more at t-mobile.com
Network fastest based on media and
overall combined 5G speeds according to
analysis by UCLA of speed test
intelligence data for q1 2023 c5g device
coverage and access details at
t-mobile.com
well I think you're actually uh very
very nice
I think most the times that you and I
have had a real argument or I've seen
you lose your temper alcohol wasn't
involved at all you might be right it's
just you know you see red when you see
red and then you don't contain yourself
and mostly I've seen you go after other
people not me which is fun I like it
when it's not me oh no you don't no I
like Paris because you're there with me
no I just distanced myself very quickly
and I say what can you do she has rabies
she was bit by a very sick rabbit last
week I I drove here but did not drive
back that's how that's that's where I
was I I took a I took a lift home yeah
well I thought because we're all going
to be sampling ahead of time
I I drove I I mean I I made the plan to
uh get a lift here and then get a lift
home so I just knew that because I'd be
having some alcohol like let's not even
mess with that here no I'm responsible
well I'm sorry but yes I didn't leave my
car here wait so you're saying that you
you're saying Sona that you thought
there's a chance that you might not
drink yeah I really oh I
legitimately thought I would be okay
especially
saying I'll take I'll be all right
I'll be fine I know it's hilarious I
wrote in with Sona knowing exactly that
I could get a ride home from my wife who
was coming in yes I'm not driving home
there's no way and Sona was my ride in
yeah so did you leave your car here I
did yeah and I was prepared for a ticket
but I that's how I did it when I was
younger I would drive somewhere leave my
car there and come I've had my car towed
three times right like that's just part
of the world
I love that you could have that kind of
Reckless abandon yeah you probably if
you had to you would leave your car
somewhere yeah now but when I was
younger I would have been worried about
it being towed oh yeah but if it's towed
you just find out where it's towed and
then you get it back well I think it
sounds so reasonable yeah and you make
it sound enjoyable that's the worst I've
had to do that just leave your car
places and then they tow it and you find
out where it was towed and yeah Target
towed or ticket it today I mean uh when
we no no it didn't I got it was fine
when I came back it was fine wow yeah I
know I love worked out but it's been
there have been times when it's gotten
towed where crazy Sona came out and I
would you know yell at people but it you
know it didn't work